today we're doing our first ever  drive-through event  gives applicants an opportunity to come  and  be someone besides a piece of paper be  someone behind just an application we  want to see people we want to meet  people  we want to get people back to work they  can get interviewed on the spot and  within 72 hours we'll contact them  with a resolution i was so excited when  i found out about that  i am currently applying for positions at  circa the position i just applied for  was front desk agent the process was  actually really simple  we want to get people out of their  houses we want to get them back to work  we want to  show vegas you know we're open we're  ready for those tours to come back  please have your resume available and  please apply before coming down we do  have computers available for  them to use however to make this process  go a little bit quicker  and so you're not waiting outside please  apply first